CHARGES.
>> IT IS CERTIFIED AND THEY HAD
LECTORS, AND THEY ATTEMPTED TO
REPLACE THE ELECTORS BECAUSE
TRUMP DID NOT LIKE THE RESULTS.
AND NOW, JOINING US IS KELLY
CORDERO AND JONATHAN DEAN, AND
NOW, IF YOU CAN BEGIN WITH US,
ON THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INVESTIGATION, WHAT DOES IT TELL
YOU THAT THE INVESTIGATORS ARE
GOING TO SUCH BATTLE OVER THE
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE CLAIMS THAT
FOUR FORMER TRUMP WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIAL, AND IS THAT ABOUT THE
FORMER OFFICIALS THOSE AROUND
TRUMP OR ABOUT TRUMP HIMSELF?
>> I THINK IT IS A LEGAL ISSUE
AND IT IS BEING USED AS A DEVICE
TO SUPPRESS TESTIMONY.
TRUMP IS CALLING ON A VERY THIN
AND UNLITIGATED AREA OF
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
BIG PICTURE, THERE IS NO
PRIVILEGE.
BIDEN HAS SAID THAT HE IS NOT
INVOKING EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE,
AND THE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT
WHICH WAS ADOPTED IN 1978 SAYS
IT IS THE PRESIDENT'S CALL.
HE IS THE INCUMBENT, AND HE IS
THE ONE WHO HAS AUTHORITY OVER
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE, BUT THERE
IS AN OPINION FROM THE YEAR
BEFORE 1977 THAT SAYS PRIOR
PRESIDENTS CAN INVOKE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, BUT THERE ARE NO
DOCUMENTS INVOLVED IN THIS, AND
THIS IS THE EXCHANGES BETWEEN
THEMSELVES AND TRUMP, AND HE
CLAIMING EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
OVER THAT, AND THAT IS NOT
LITIGATED, AND THEY DON'T WANT
TO HAVE TO LITIGATE THIS,
BECAUSE IT WOULD GO TO THE
DISTRICT COURT, THE COURT OF
APPEALS AND TO THE SUPREME
COURT, AND WITH A 6-3, AND THE
SIXTH BEING VERY UNPREDICTABLE
SINCE THEY DON'T ALWAYS FOLLOW
THE LAW, THIS IS A TROUBLESOME
AREA, AND THIS WHAT THEY ARE
GEARING UP FOR, AND IT APPEARS
TO ME, AND THEY ARE GETTING
READY TO MOUNT A FIGHT IF
NECESSARY.
>> KERRY, YOU HAVE OFTEN WISE
WISELY
INJECTED SOME CAUTION AS TO HOW
FAR THIS INVESTIGATION MAY GO,
AND BASED ON THE LATEST MOVES,
WHO DO YOU SEE AS THE TARGET OF
THE DOJ STEPS THE HERE?
FOLKS IN TRUMP'S CIRCLE, AS I
ASKED JOHN, OR TRUMP HIMSELF
POTENTIALLY?
>> WELL, I THINK IT IS
DEFINITELY FOLKS IN HIS CIRCLE,
INCLUDING POTENTIALLY HIS FORMER
CHIEF OF STAFF, AND THE PEOPLE
CLOSE TO HIM IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
THIS MOST RECENT INFORMATION
REALLY DEMONSTRATES AS A
PRACTICAL MATTER THAT SOME OF
THE WITNESSES INCLUDING THE
FORMER PENCE ADVISERS HAVE MORE
TO SAY.
SO, THERE IS CLEARLY SOME
INFORMATION THAT THEY COULD HAVE
PROVIDED TO THE GRAND JURY AND
DID NOT AND THEY ARE POTENTIALLY
RELYING ON THE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, EVEN THOUGH THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT IS NOT, AND
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW THEY CAN GET
MORE OF THAT EVIDENCE, AND THE
ABILITY OF THE GRAND JURY AND
THE ABILITY TO GET INFORMATION
FROM WITNESSES WITH A PURPOSEFUL
LAWFUL SUBPOENA IS HOW THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT DETERMINES IF
THEY HAVE POTENTIAL CHARGES
AGAINST INDIVIDUALS, AND WHETHER
THOSE ARE FOLKS CLOSE TO THE
PRESIDENT OR POTENTIALLY THE
FORMER PRESIDENT HIMSELF.
BUT IT IS AN INVESTIGATIVE STEP,
AND IT IS GOING TO INDICATE THAT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
THINKING THROUGH AHEAD OF TIME,
BECAUSE TRADITIONALLY THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WOULD BE
ARGUING TO PROTECT PRESIDENTIAL
PREROGATIVES.
>> AND EVAN, YOU CAN LEARN A LOT
ON THE WITNESSES THAT THE
PROSECUTORS ARE ASKING THE
WITNESS, AND YOU ARE LEARNING A
LOT ABOUT THE QUESTION, AND WHAT
DO YOU KNOW AND WHAT IS IT
TELLING US?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, JIM, THESE
TWO WITNESSES IN PARTICULAR,
JACOB AND SHORT, THEY WERE ASKED
DIRECTLY ABOUT THE PRESSURE
CAMPAIGN, AND THEY ANSWERED
THOSE QUESTIONS, AND THEY SPENT
HOURS TALKING TO THE GRAND JURY
ABOUT THOSE MEETINGS, AND
ESPECIALLY THE ONE ON JANUARY
4th WHERE WE KNOW THAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT AND JOHN
EASTMAN WERE PRESSURING PENCE TO
SAY THAT HE HAD THE POWER TO SET
ASIDE THE ELECTION RESULTS, BUT
WHAT I AM TOLD THEY WERE ABLE TO
ANSWER A LOT OF THE QUESTIONS
AROUND THE EDGES, AND PROVIDED A
LOT OF INFORMATION, AND EVEN
THOUGH THEY COULD NOT REACH THE
EXACT DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN THE
FORMER PRESIDENT AND VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE FOR INSTANCE OR
BETWEEN MARK SHORT AND GREG
JACOB AND THE FORMER PRESIDENT,
THERE IS A LOT OF INFORMATION
THAT THEY WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE
TO THE GRAND JURY, AND SO WHAT
WE CAN EXPECT AS CARRIE IS
POINTING OUT, THIS IS A
BEGINNING, AND WE EXPECT THEY
WILL BE COMING BACK, AND ABLE TO
COME BACK TO THEM, AND TRY TO,
YOU KNOW, GET THROUGH THE
PRESIDENTIAL PRIVILEGE ISSUE TO
TRY TO GET ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION FROM THE WITNESSES.
>> JOHN, WE LEARNED THAT THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE SPOKE WITH
SECRETARY MNUCHIN, AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THEY ASKED ABOUT
IS THIS EFFORT BY JOHN CARL TOVS
OWN CABINET MEMBER, AND WHY
WOULD THE COMMITTEE FOCUS IN ON
THAT?
WOULD IT BE THE STATE OF MIND,
AND WHAT THE PRESIDENT WAS
CAPABLE OF THEN?
>> IT IS CERTAINLY SHOWING THE
FEELING OF THOSE AROUND HIM
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S STATE OF
MIND.
IT IS NOT A GOOD PROCESS TO
INVOKE THE CONSTITUTION TO PLACE
HIM ON A DISABLED LIST.
IT IS REALLY AWKWARD.
I HAPPENED TO WORK ON THAT
AMENDMENT WHEN I WAS WITH THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, AND
THE VICE PRESIDENT HAS TO SEND A
LETTER TO THE SPEAKER AND THE
PRESIDENT PROTEM OF THE SENATE
TELLING HIM THAT THE PRESIDENT
IS UNCAPABLE OF CARRYING OUT HIS
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION.
THE PRESIDENT, ALL HE HAS TO DO
IS TO NEUTER THAT IS TO SEND A
LETTER SAYING THAT I AM
PERFECTLY CAPABLE, AND THESE
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO GET ME OUT
OF THE WAY, AND THEY DON'T LIKE
MY DECISION, AND TO PUT THAT IN
PLAY, THEN THE VICE PRESIDENT
HAS TO SEND ANOTHER LETTER BACK
TO THE CONGRESS, AND SAY, NO,
NO, HE IS IN BAD SHAPE, AND THEN
THE CONGRESS HAS FOUR DAYS TO
RESOLVE IT.
I THINK THAT, YOU KNOW, IT IS
LIKELY THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
RULED IN FAVOR OF TRUMP EVEN IF
THEY DID NOT LIKE HIS POLICY,
BECAUSE THIS AMENDMENT WAS NOT
DESIGNED FOR THIS ACTIVITY.
>> IT IS A GOOD POINT, BECAUSE
IT IS NOT A SWIFT OR EASY
PROCESS, AND CARRIE, YOU THINK
THAT THE COMMITTEE COULD HURT
ITS CASE BY GOING DOWN THE PATH
OF INVESTIGATING 25th, AND TELL
US WHY.
>> SO I THINK THAT THE COMMITTEE
IF THEY WERE TO ARGUE WHAT IS
THEIR INTEREST TO DO THAT, AND
IT IS TO CREATE A HISTORICAL
RECORD OF WHAT TRANSPIRED
SURROUNDING EVENTS OF JANUARY
6th, AND FROM THE HISTORICAL
PERSPECTIVE, I UNDERSTAND WHY
THEY MIGHT BE INTERESTED IN IT,
BUT IT IS NOT A GREAT USE OF
THEIR TIME IF WHAT THEY ARE
REALLY TRYING TO DO, WHICH THEY
HAVE COMMUNICATED BOTH IN THE
HEARINGS AND IN MANY OF THE
OTHER STATEMENTS AS THE HEARINGS
HAVE TAKEN PLACE IS THAT THEY
ARE TRYING TO DEMONSTRATE THAT
THERE IS A CRIMINAL CASE TO BE
MADE AGAINST THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WHICH IS SOMETHING
THAT THEY ARE TRY TO PRODUCE THE
EVIDENCE THAT IS RELEVANT TO A
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INVESTIGATION, AND WITH THAT
PERSPECTIVE, ARGUING OR
EXPLORING IN MORE DETAIL THE
ARGUMENTS THAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WAS LACKING IN MENTAL
CAPACITY ACTUALLY IS COUNTER TO
A POTENTIAL EFFORT TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT HE HAD INTENT
AND THAT HE WAS OF SOUND MIND
AND PURPOSELY TRYING TO OVERTURN
THE ELECTION, AND SO THEY HAVE
TO POTENTIALLY THINK THROUGH